let's do another conic section
identification problem so I have four Y
squared minus 50 X is equal to 25 x
squared plus 16 y plus 109 so the first
thing I like to do is to group all of
the x and y terms onto one side of the
equation and leave all the constants on
the other side so let's do that so on
the left hand side I'll put the 4y
squared
4y squared and actually I'm also going
to group all the X and y terms in this
step so u 4y squared
let's move this 16 Y on to the left-hand
side so if I subtract 16 Y from both
sides of this equation I get minus 16 Y
minus 16 Y on the left-hand side and of
course it will disappear on the
right-hand side and then I want to
subtract the 25 x squared from both
sides of this equation so I get minus 25
x squared minus 50 X that's that right
there and then I'll leave this 109 on
the right-hand side is equal to 109 and
now that we have the XS and the Y's on
the same side of the equation we know
what type of we know the general
direction we're going to go in because
they're on the same side they have
different coefficients and one is
positive and one is negative so that
lets us know that we're dealing with a
hyperbola so let's complete the square
and get it into the standard form so the
easiest way to complete the square is if
you have a 1 coefficient on the y
squared of the x squared term so let's
factor out a 4 in this case so you get 4
times y squared minus 4y I'm going to
add something later when I complete the
square minus 25 times x squared plus
let's see minus 50 divided by minus 25
is 2 plus 2x I'm going to add something
later is equal to 109 and these things
we're going to add those are what
complete the square make these things a
perfect square
so if I take this you have a minus four
here I take half of that number and this
is just completing the square I
encourage you to watch the video on
completing the square where I explain
why this works but I take I have a minus
four I take half of that it's minus 2
and then minus 2 squared is plus 4 now I
can't do one thing to one side of the
equation without doing to the other and
I didn't add a 4 to the left-hand side
of the equation I actually added a 4
times 4 right because you have this 4
multiplying it out in front so I did a
16 to decide to the left side of the
equation so I have to also add it to the
right-hand side of the equation right
this is equivalent to also having a plus
16 here that might make it a little bit
clearer right when you factor it out
then it becomes a 4 we would have added
a 16 up here as well
likewise if we take half of this number
here half of 2 is 1 1 squared is 1 we
didn't add a 1 to the left-hand side of
the equation we added a 1 times minus 25
so you want to put a minus 25 here and
likewise this would have been the same
thing as adding a minus 25 up here and
you do a minus 25 over here and now what
does this become this Y the Y terms
become 4 times y minus 2 squared Y minus
2 squared what I want to review
factoring a polynomial if that if you
found that a little confusing that step
minus 25 times X plus 1 squared that's
that right there X plus 1 squared is
equal to let's see 109 plus 16 is 25
minus 25 is equals 100 we're almost
there so we want a 1 here so let's
divide both sides of this equation by
100 so if you will get Y minus 2 squared
4 divided by 100 is the same thing as 1
over 25 so this becomes over 25 minus C
25 over 100 the same thing as 1 over 4
so this becomes x plus 1 squared over 4
is equal
to one and there you have it we have it
in standard form and yes indeed we do
have we do have a hyperbola now let's
graph this hyperbola so the first thing
we know is where where the center of
this hyperbola is the center of this
hyperbola is at the point X is equal to
minus 1 so it's at X is equal to minus 1
Y is equal to 2 and let's figure out the
asymptotes of this hyperbola so if this
was this is Way IO is doing cuz I always
forget the actual formula if this was
kind of in it centered at 0 and it looks
something like this Y squared over 25
minus x squared over 4 is equal to 1 I
do this to figure out what the
asymptotes would have been if we were
centered at 0 because it's a lot easier
to deal with these equations than to
deal with these so we could solve we
multiply both sides by 100 we're kind of
unwinding what we just did so if you
actually let's multiply both sides by
let's multiply both sides by 25 so then
you get Y squared minus 25 over 4x
squared is equal to 25 and then I'll
just go right here and then if I add 25
over 4x squared to both sides I get Y
squared is equal to 25 over 4x squared
plus 25 and so Y is equal to the plus or
minus square root of 25 over 4x squared
plus 25 and like always the asymptotes
the hyperbola will never equal the
asymptotes or intersect the asymptotes
but it's what the the graph approaches
as X approaches positive and negative
infinity so as X as X approaches
positive and negative infinity and you
learn the concept of limits later on but
I think you get it at this point because
that's what the idea of what asymptotes
even is is that you know as X gets
really large you're approaching this
line so as X approaches positive or
negative infinity as we've done in the
previous videos this term starts to
matter a lot less because this term is
huge so then Y is approximately equal to
plus or minus the square root of just
this
and the square root of just this term is
five halves X so though that would those
would be our asymptotes if we were
centered at zero but of course we're
centered at negative 1/2 so let's graph
that and then we could figure out if
it's an upward opening or a downward
opening upward opening or downward
opening graph okay we're at Center
negative 1/2 let me see so I want to be
in D it's my y-axis this is my x-axis
and we're centered at -1 and then 1/2
that's the center and then you know this
would have been the two lines if we were
if we were of the asymptotes if we were
centered at zero but now this tells us
the slope of the two asymptotes so the
asymptotes are going to intersect at the
center of our hyperbola so to speak so
these are the slopes of the two
asymptotes so one is positive five over
two so positive five over two means if
we go over to so one two and X we go up
five so 1 2 3 4 5 so we'll end up right
over there so I can draw that line you
just need two points for a line so that
line would look like that and then the
other asymptote is minus 5 over 2 so for
every 2 we go over to the right we go
down 5 so 1 2 1 2 3 4 5 so we end up
right about there and so that line would
look like it would look like that good
enough so those are the two asymptotes
and they go on forever in those
directions and now we could think of it
two ways we could either say okay does
if we look at well let's look at the
original one I'll actually look at this
one Ken and if we look at if it was
centered at 0 could X equal 0 well sure
X could equal 0 if x is 0 then Y squared
over 25 equals 1 Y squared equals 25 Y
would be plus or minus 5
five right so in this case this term
could be equals zero so we could say
that X could equal negative one right if
X is equal to negative one then Y minus
two squared over 25 will equal one let's
do that let's set if X is equal to
negative one X I was using the line tool
is equal to negative one then what is
this expression become I don't want to
lose it so I'll write it right there so
then you get Y minus two squared over 25
this becomes zero minus zero is equal to
one so you get Y minus two squared over
25 is equal to one y minus two squared
is equal to 25 just multiply both sides
by 25 y minus 2 is equal to plus or
minus I'm just taking the square root of
both sides 5 so y minus 2 is equal to a
positive 5 or Y minus 2 is equal to
minus 5 add 2 to both sides of this you
get Y is equal to 7 add 2 to both sides
of this you get Y is equal to minus 3 so
we know that the points minus 1 7 and
minus 1 minus 3 are both on this graph
so minus 1 that's here 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
minus 1 7 and minus 1 1 2 3 are both on
this graph so let that lets us know
since we're inside here that this tells
us that this is kind of a vertical
asymptote and another way to guess it is
if you see that oh the Y term is the Y
squared term is positive but either way
or the other way to think about it is
when you take the positive square root
right when you take the positive square
root you're always going to be a little
bit above the asymptote right that's the
other way to think about this that we're
always going to be a little bit and this
is this is the positive square the
positive square root is the top line so
we're always going to be a little bit
above the asymptote right these this is
the asymptote we're always a little bit
above it and as obviously this number
gets larger this
starts to matter a lot less so the graph
is going to look something like this
it's going to come down and then go off
and never quite touch the asymptotes but
approach it so it's going to get really
close to the asymptotes and then go off
and go off in that direction anyway hope
you found that helpful this was a
slightly hairier problem so it should be
instructive